j'ai simplement perdu
aujourd'hui je peux dire que je pense au
liban
c'était trop cher pour garde de soldes
en wec
c'est un parcours tellement personnel en
compagnie de débiles et de joie j'ai
envie de mettre en lumière ce moment où
ils se sont choisis
alors vous avez peut-être vu dans les
derniers mois cette série documentaire
histoire de coming out c'était sûrement
et compagnie une réalisation 2d binh
choix est une artiste multidisciplinaire
le connu comme comédienne comme
chanteuse puis pas de limite dans son
rôle dans sa créativité est lutte contre
l'homophobie et c'est pourquoi le fait
cette série de l'année dernière et elle
va recevoir d'une minute à l'autre le
prix laurent mais coach sean qui est un
militant de pendant des décennies pour
la reconnaissance des droits des jambes
étaient qu est donc pour souligner
justement sa contribution à la cause
elle a accepté de nous parler depuis le
lieu où elle va recevoir ce prix des
bulles et le choix d'abord bonsoir et
félicitations qu'est ce que ça
représente pour vous de recevoir ce prix
tout à l'heure
c'est énorme pour moi je vous avoue que
je dois avouer que ça m'émeut davantage
je pense qu'un prix d'interprétation
parce qu'évidemment je veux dire ça
vient me chercher profondément dans mon
identité dans qui je suis dans ce que je
défends dans ce que j'ai envie de mettre
en lumière puisse être reconnaissant
cela me touche vraiment vraiment
beaucoup puis c'est un grand honneur je
sais c'est la première fois que je
reçois un prix de ce genre depuis ouais
c'est juste très fébrile évidemment il
ya comme une entrave aux anglais sortira
car je suppose et le mot juste en
français les mots justes en français
vous l'avez fait c'est tardivement vous
êtes personnalité très connue très
populaire mais pour vous ça s'est bien
passé mais est ce que c'est important
quand on est une personnalité publique
comme vous de le dire de le faire pour
aider les autres et permettent de lutter
contre l'homophobie
mais moi je pense que oui en fait je
pense que plus on sera à faire notre
coming out d'un pion on sera visible et
plus on va engager un dialogue et plus
on va faire tomber des barrières on va
on va on va faire tomber l'ignorance de
certaines personnes et donc
pour moi c'est quelque chose d'important
que je veux défendre après ça je
comprends complètement le parcours
personnel de chaque personne c'est pas
tout le monde qui ont envie
nécessairement chacun le vit à sa façon
mais vraiment pour moi en fait je
pouvais pas ne pas le faire parce que je
sais que la normale
la normale la même mais moi je suis la
même personne à la télé que dans la vie
je veux cette cohérence là et bien je
veux utiliser ma tribune pour les
personnes qui en ont pas je dire ceci
ç'a toujours été clair est-ce que ça a
été seul impact aussi de la série
documentaire et peut-être avec ce prix
aujourd'hui de vous détendre en
communion avec les gens qui ont besoin
d'être guidés dans cette démarche là
parce que vous dis aussi rêver du jour
où c'est plus nécessaire d'en faire donc
c'est tellement chose normale que d'être
accepté
oui absolument absolument c'est un peu
l'objectif que j'avais avec la série au
départ après ça j'ai nuancer un peu
cette réflexion là en me disant il ya
quand même des gens pour qui le coming
out s'inscrit dans une émancipation dans
un un processus qui est important pour
eux donc le but je pense pas que c'est
de plus en faire mais le but c'est que
c'est que ça brise plus des familles
c'est que ça les gens jeudi a perdu leur
emploi pour ça et et je dirai tout ce
qui arrive c'est vivent pas de quels
gens vivent plus de mots phobie de
transe remis tout ça donc donc oui c'est
ce que c'est ce que je voulais mettre en
lumière ou es ce que vous avez vécu de
l'homophobie au cours des années et que
votre
un petit peu je dois avouer que j'ai
j'ai été très très chanceux si on veut
dans le sens que je sais que des
personnalités publiques en ont vécu plus
que moi
mais je suis témoin
d'homophobie j'ai déjà toutes sortes de
gens qui m'ont écrit des centaines de
messages pour me raconter leur histoire
et c'est complètement atroce des fois ce
qui se passe puis oui on dit qu'au
québec on est bien on est chanceux
mais il ya encore du chemin à faire et
lyon caen fois encore emballés puis
puisque je trouve beau par exemple puis
c'est mon ami simon boulerice qui me dit
ça dans la série c'est que je trouve que
maintenant on pointe plus du doigt
l'homophobe que l'homosexuel et ce pour
moi ça me remplit d'espoir pour la suite
des choses qu'est ce qu'on doit dire aux
homophobes que ce qu'on doit faire pour
que pour qu'ils changent leurs visions
bain de discuter avec les gens de
discuter de concret n'est jamais
l'histoire des gens qu'on rencontre puis
d'être curieux de l'autre ça développe
notre empathie ça fait tomber
l'ignorance a fait tomber les barrières
qui on se rend compte qu'on est juste
super puis que ben l'amour c'est l'amour
et puis que ça se résume à ça en bout de
ligne c'est l'amour on veut tous être
aimé on veut tous aimés puis c'est tout
donc je pense que oui c'est de parler
sinon c'est pas avoir peur il ya des
sondages de l'egypte qui a été fait
justement par la fondation émergence par
par les jets la firme léger qui révélait
que 65 pour 65% des personnes lgbt qu de
plus ont été victimes au moins une fois
de leur serment sexuelles ou
psychologiques au travail 15 % des
québécois ont démissionné à cause du
travail peu inquiet 21% déjà pensé le
faire ça sans parler des côtes suicide
de rihanna du suicide associés à cette
difficulté de
d'assumer en fait de comprendre je vous
laisse me l'expliquer mais on peut pas
prendre à la légère ce phénomène le bien
au contraire ça a des conséquences
importantes sur l'avenant j'en suis
membre est
absolument absolument je veux dire
encore dernièrement ici au québec il ya
un jeune de dix ans qui s'est
malheureusement enlevé la vie parce que
il était une personne trans puis ça
c'est heavy véhicules et vivait de la
transphobie avec sopi mais il n'y avait
pas les batailles qui manquait de
ressources sur les outils nécessaires
pour traverser ça mais je dirais oui il
ya des choses terribles qui se passe
puis il faut plus que ça se passe et
nous nous parler aux parents aussi parce
que des rejets ils se font des rejets
qui sont subies par les personnes qui
sortent du placard auprès de leurs
familles
mais oui absolument puis encore une fois
ça repose sur je pense sur beaucoup
d'ignorance sur beaucoup de parts sur
beaucoup de préjugés qui en 2022 à mon
avis en plus leur place et et tombe de
plus en plus puis on doit continuer de
les faire tomber
débile en switch ou pendant leurs pauses
pendant quand vous branchez je vous ai
appris qu une partie de la réforme du
code civil a été adopté hier que je
recueille le goût de vous demander comme
une formidable comédienne de me re jouer
votre réaction vous avez pendant la
pause quand je vous ai appris notamment
que désormais on emploiera le mot par an
plus tôt que père ou mère sur les
registres d'identité civile et qu'on
pourrait on aurait pu à caser là un
beauf amenons pourra indiquer son
identité de genre dites moi ce que vous
avez des parts dans la poche
je ne savais pas j'étais pas au courant
et c'est absolument génial c'est
absolument génial je samassa me remplit
de joie alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement pour des par exemple des
couples gay qui ont des enfants
désormais ils vont pouvoir assumer
pleinement leur identité
ben oui absolument absolument parce que
c'est sûr que ça doit ça doit créer de
la confusion ça doit créer des dessins
confort tu sais moi je suis papa ramé
mais je connais des gens est justement
d'aider deux femmes veulent où ils
veulent pas s'identifier comme un père
ou comme un homme donc il y avait un
espèce de flou et que je suis très
heureuse que con con con qu on ait réglé
que ça continue dans ce sens là parce
que parce que oui dans la bureaucratie
dans toute la paperasse et tous mais il
ya des choses un petit ménage à faire
aussi tous très bien alors qu'est ce
qu'on vous souhaite pour l'avenir vous
allez continuer cet engagement-là contre
le bo phobie
ben oui absolument je vais continuer
parce que ben j'ai pas d'autre choix à
mon avis parce que c'est si c'est ça
c'est tout naturel puis puis ouais je
vais continuer avec joie je sais pas ce
sera sous quelle forme mais je sais que
de juste à être visible dans les médias
avec ma femme ça en fait déjà pour
certaines personnes qui m'écrivent puis
ce pour moi c'est c'est mon plus gros
engagement au quotidien oui pour voit
d'ailleurs dans certaines publicités des
couples gays qui des compagnies les
banques mettent à l'affiché tout ça donc
ce oui ça contribue à rendre un message
positif alors je rappelle que vous avez
saisies
non mais en fait j'avais juste dire que
oui puis je me suis toujours très on est
très excités quand on voit très heureuse
qu'on voit un couple de lesbiennes ou un
couple de guy dans une publicité et
c'est ça fait la différence parce que
comme personne de la communauté lgbt que
plus on a besoin tout entier puis
sincèrement anne-marie quand on voit ce
pour une personne lesbiennes ça vient
nous chercher dans le ventre à un
endroit qui fait vraiment du bien qui
est vraiment ce sentiment là bas on en a
on en a tous besoin on a tous besoin de
s'identifier puis je vous dire que moi
ça me j'adore ce à chaque fois que j'en
vois à la télé
ça me fait du bien
beaucoup de villageois et je rappelle
que dans quelques instants on va vous le
rendre mes coaches un grand militant
contre l'homophobie pour la
reconnaissance des droits des personnes
lgbt cul qui nous a quittés déjà depuis
un moment mais bonne soirée à vous mais
célébrez bien au revoir
merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit